10,6 Millionen corona-masken 1,4
Millionen Schutzkittel dazu eine
Millionen Schutzbrillen 100.000
Handschuhe all das wird in
Nordrhein-Westfalen thermisch entsorgt
also auf gut deutsch es wird verbrannt
weil angeblich das
Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum abgelaufen ist
das gab die Landesregierung unbekannt
eingekauft wurde dieses Material unter
dem damaligen Ministerpräsidenten Armin
Laschet der das übrigens zum Teil über
Kontakte seines influencers Dollar shit
bestellt hatte er die Empörung ist groß
gefährlich alle Medien wirklich neu sind
solche Meldungen nicht Sachsen
Sachsen-Anhalt Thüringen muss mehrere
hunderttausend Impfdosen zerstören und
auch der Bund gehabt zu dass 4,6
Millionen Dosen abgelaufen sein erleben
wir hier eine Steuergeld Vernichtung in
astronomischer Höhe wer hat da den
Überblick verloren wer trägt da die
Verantwortung wenn gleichzeitig die
Bürger mit innere höheren Abgaben
belastet werden das besprechen wir jetzt
hier Herrn sie waren zu Beginn der
corona-krise noch Chef eines
Gesundheitsamts während sie damals
erlebt wurde da erstmal gekauft gekauft
gekauft was nur geht also am Anfang der
corona-krise war es ja so das ist mir
gar kein Material da war das ging
relativ schnell zu Ende das Material und
dann wurde versucht zu kaufen soweit
eben noch ging das gelang aber nicht
mehr die Gesundheitsämter waren relativ
schnell am Ende mit dem Material und
dann kam ja tatsächlich diese diese
Geschichte auf mit den community-masken
mit den Stoffmasken wo ich dann auch
relativ schnell gesagt habe na ja das
ist alles andere nur keine
Schutzmaßnahme sondern das ist
vielleicht ein netter solidarischer Akt
aber eine tatsächliche Schutzwirkung hat
es nicht um das Ganze kurz zu machen wir
waren also keinesfalls vorbereitet auf
diese Pandemie in Sachen Schutzmaterial
also erstmal musste dann wenn es gab
gekauft werden
und zum Teil zu wirklichen Preisen und
jetzt wird aber alles verbrannt das
merkt man auch brauchen wir gar nicht
alles ist Zeug ein bisschen Ablaufdatum
und so hat sie das nicht
Empörung findet man das falsche Wort ist
verwundert mich tatsächlich es gibt ja
wohl anscheinend der Verfallsdatum ich
frage mich berufliche Form der Empörung
glaube ich die Verwunderung ja wie viele
hier höflich bleiben ich frage mich halt
warum kann man das vielleicht in
anderweitig nutzen vielleicht kann man
seine warum bringt das nicht in andere
Länder die vielleicht auch brauchen
können ich will ja auch den Sinn und
Zweck von Masken gar nicht abstreiten
aber eben nur in bestimmten settings in
bestimmten Fällen ich bin mir sicher
dass andere Länder davon profitieren
könnten die jetzt einfach thermisch zu
verwerten das heißt auf gut auf gut
deutsch einfach zu verbrennen weil man
so
wahnsinnig viele gekauft haben sind ja
Steuergelder also eigentlich wäre nett
Masken verbrannt sondern es werden die
Steuergelder verbrannt und das verwundet
mich schon sehr ja Verwunderung Empörung
vielleicht bei Herrn ist gerade
angesprochen da geht es um Steuergelder
im Prinzip ein Steuergelder Verband ja
und Steuergeld ist ja schon eine
Beschönigung
Sachverstandes es ist ja Geld der
Steuerzahler es ist ja unser Geld das
ist nicht das Staatsgeld ist nicht
Steuergeld sondern Geld der Steuerzahler
dass der Staat treuhänderisch bekommen
hat und es im Sinne der allgemeine zu
verwenden und bei diesem Beispiel gerade
in der corona-krise aber vielen anderen
sehen wir einfach dass die
Verantwortlichkeiten erodieren das ist
im Endeffekt bei großen großen Ausgaben
wie auch bei großen großen Versagen kein
gibt der die Verantwortung übernimmt der
sich hinstellt es werden auf Prozesse
auf Notlagen verwiesen auf
strukturdefizite auf Zwangslagen die man
habe müssen befolgen man hat anfangs zu
wenig Masken gehabt dann viel zu viel
und was ich den Skandal fast schon finde
ist zum einen ähm wir hören bei
Lebensmittel ständig
Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum das ist nur
eine unverbindliche Richtschnur also man
kann die Milch auch noch eine Woche
später trinken bei Dosen ein halbes Jahr
noch länger warum muss das jetzt glaube
ich eingehalten werden zweitens ist
verbrennen ist natürlich vom Symbolwert
ein sehr dramatischer Vorgang dort wird
wirklich unser Geld verbrannt hätten wir
wirklich eine andere Lösung finden
müssen und das dritte was mich dann doch
am meisten oder am ehesten gehört ist
die Tatsache dass wir Grund zur
Vermutung haben das zu überteuerten
Preisen eingekauft worden ist er gibt
auch teilweise Untersuchungen
Untersuchungsausschüsse wir haben
teilweise betrug auch mit Corona
Teststationen also es haben sich leider
sehr viele Leute in dieser Pandemie die
Taschen voll gemacht und da schließt
sich der Kreis zu dem was Sie gesagt
haben es liegt daran dass es keine Pläne
gab bzw es gab Pandemie Plänen und die
wurden nicht befolgt das heißt wir haben
große Städte die immer sagen wenn was
ganz schlimmes passiert sagt ja Schulze
auch immer da mache ich nur eine
Schublade auf ist nur ein Plan drin dann
ist der Plan wieder veraltet und man
befolgt ihn nicht also wir haben nicht
nur ein Umsetzung sondern auch ein
Erkenntnisproblem das hat mich nicht
aufhört dass das müssen wir den Arzt
gehen unsere Runde fragen das Ablauf
Mindesthaltbarkeit bei so einer
Schutzweste das ist mir nicht ganz klar
ein Grund aus ihrer Sicht also können
Sie uns das erklären
das einzige was man vielleicht
vernünftigerweise oder anziehen könnte
deswegen das Argument das Materialien
natürlich auch im Laufe der Zeit einfach
ermüden und vielleicht deshalb nimm das
so gut funktioniert aber ich denke mir
ist wie in der ganzen Pandemie wir haben
da viel zu wenig Datum ich schätze mir
auch diese diese Daten sind einfach
gewürfelt worden man hat gesagt naja so
ungefähr wird es schon passen ich kann
mir ganz schwer vorstellen
dass es jetzt sein muss dass man es
genau jetzt zu diesem Datum jetzt
einfach verbrennen muss ich komme gut
vorstellen dass die mindestens noch ein
Jahr länger halten würden und so auch
sind und Zweck erfüllen hat das gerade
angesprochen da gab es viele
Bereicherungen mit Masken mit allen
möglichen Deals die dort geschlossen
wurden wir haben das jetzt eben gerade
auch in der Sendung schon gehört ich
habe mir auch ein paar Beispiele in
Bayern Frau Hohlmeier Andreas Handler
die Tochter von dem CSU konnte die hat
Millionen abgesand einfach nur für die
Vermittlung
48,3 Millionen Euro Honorar hast du den
Eindruck der wurde quasi auf Teufel
kommen raus bestellt auch um sich
einfach finanziell zu bereichern und
dein Geschäft zu machen
ja also das war ja das lag ja schon ganz
nah beieinander die ist auf Teufel komm
raus jetzt schnell was zu beschaffen und
dann persönlichen Kontakte anzurufen
sage ich jetzt erst jetzt Armin Laschet
der beispielsweise seinen Sohn gefragt
hat ob er ihn vermitteln kann in Kontakt
zum Unternehmen wo angeblich keine
Provisionen geflossen sind und man hat
es ja auch dann so vom Land NRW zum
Beispiel spezifisch gesehen die haben
eine rüber bekommen dafür dass der
Landesrechnungshof gesagt hat ihr habt
es viel zu großzügig ausgelegt dass die
Vergabebestimmungen von den Aufträgen
her was er sowieso schon gelockert wurde
im März 2020 vom Bund und der NRW
Gesundheitsminister hat ja auch nach dem
Motto so gesagt damals ja wenn wenn man
den Landesrechnungshof nicht am Arsch
kleben hat nach der Pandemie dann hat
man irgendwas falsch gemacht damit
wollte er natürlich auch ähnliches
rechtfertigen lassen und diese Richtung
geht fangen wir direkt bei der Politik
nach waren unsere Steuergelder da gut
aufgehoben während der Pandemie wurde
verantwortungsvoll mit unseren
Steuergeldern umgegangen also ich glaube
wir haben viele Punkte über die wir
reden müssen was in der Pandemie falsch
gelaufen ist sicherlich auch beim Thema
Vergabe Beschaffung ich ich glaube nicht
zu Unrecht gibt es da auch
parlamentarische Untersuchungsausschüsse
die auch eingefordert werden ich glaube
da ist einiges zum Aufarbeiten
wobei ich ein bisschen in der Diskussion
vielleicht für den ausgleichswagen will
wenn ich mich zurück entzünde als Corona
ausbrach im Februar 2022 März 2020 dann
hatten wir schon die Situation dass wir
wirklich gar nichts hatten da war der
Ruf nach Masken nach Schutzausrüstung
relativ stark und da war es natürlich so
und da verstehe ich auch jeden Landrat
da verstehe ich jeden grießmanager der
sagt ich beschaffe was irgendwie geht
die Frage ist sozusagen für mich wann
wurden die Sachen erstmal gekauft ja
Berlin bleiben da gab es Testsender die
haben gar nicht getestet das hätte ich
ihm ja jetzt gerade gesagt also
gerade sozusagen gesagt ich glaube das
Thema Maske ist vielleicht gar nicht das
und was ich mich jetzt aufregen würde
ich würde mich eher aufregen beim Thema
z.B Corona Test also was ist da alles
schief gelaufen warum haben wir da
keinen Kontrollmechanismus eingezogen
warum wurde das sind überprüft
persönliche Kontakte auch das sind
Punkte die aufzuklären sind aber dass
ich das Landrat der zum Beispiel
Verantwortung trägt im Krisenfall und im
Katastrophenfall was es war einfach in
dem Zeitpunkt wo mich die Krankenhäuser
anrufen ich habe keine Masken dann
vielleicht auch 150 oder 250 Prozent vom
Bedarf bestelle verstehe ich in der
politisch aufgeheizten Situation wir
haben so viele Fragen über die wir uns
ernsthaft unterhalten müssen das Thema
Masken ist ein Beiwerk aber dann lasst
uns lieber darüber sprechen was
sozusagen Anstand in dem Frage ist und
ich glaube jetzt sich darüber
aufzubringen dass er was ausläuft denn
wir hatten sie so viele Skandale von
Masken Affären also das war ja wirklich
eine Zeit lang war man beschattet von
diesen Nachrichten darüber und hat man
sich dann natürlich auch die Frage
gestellt in diesem Land wie nah ist
eigentlich Lobbyismus und Korruption
gerade wenn dann irgendeine Krise kommt
und wie weit wird das dann ausgenutzt
von Politikern da waren sehr sehr viele
dabei dieses natürlich auch nachweislich
ausgenutzt haben und man kann es nicht
schön reden das mit den Tests das ist
auch ein Problem aber was sieben ein ist
der Kosten setzen hinter ihm Verhältnis
zu den Kosten zu den Masken
ursprüngliches Problem was wir haben in
Deutschland wir waren gar nicht darauf
vorbereitet auf eine Pandemie ist gab
nichts dann war die große Verzweiflung
da die natürlich ausgenutzt wurde und
ich frage mich ernsthaft ob dieses Land
und ob die Politiker auch lernfähig sind
also wenn wir eine Pandemie wieder
kriegen würden in 10 20 Jahren
inwiefern dass ich einfach wiederholen
die Politik ganz einfach nicht recht
denn es gab zu keiner Zeit einen
Zeitpunkt wo die ganze Bevölkerung
Masken brauchte und das hieß es ja auch
am Anfang Herr draußen hat es persönlich
gesagt man braucht keine Masken
plötzlich braucht man Masken es wäre
viel viel klüger gewesen einfach zu
sagen wir brauchen die Masken für die
Krankenhäuser für den medizinischen
Bedarf und dann haben wir es irgendwann
verteilt auf die breite Bevölkerung und
dann gingen sie natürlich auch aus diese
Masken und allein durch diese Masken und
maskenpflicht hätte man ganz ganz viel
einsparen können als ich glaube da liegt
das eigentliche Problem